every morning I wake up and I make
pretend that's that my mother or
children or wife died the only
consistent in my life has been
perspective and gratitude the only
consistent in my life every morning I
wake up and I may pretend that's that my
mother or children or wife died I
promise you if you're in touch with your
feelings and you can trick yourself to
feel it even right now I felt it a
little bit and really [ __ ] hurts like
nothing else matters
I'm completely driven by gratitude I
keep things in very simple perspective
I'm thrilled and very in tune with my
ego I'm also very thrilled and in tune
with my humility I think I'm the best
and I think that if I disappear tomorrow
nobody really gives a [ __ ] and so that
yin and yang is very important to me and
so what I do consistently and have for
30 years now is I keep things in
perspective
I want legacy I think the reason I'm
liked is cuz I'll reply to somebody who
says they're on the way here to see me
talk on Twitter and reply to her like
like I I'm playing a different game I
Tyler filming today's daily be yet I met
with a former employee and he flat out
like broke the wall and he was like dude
I just have to ask you like why didn't
you take that meeting it's a former
employee one that you fired one that
came to tell you that they were sorry
for not getting it she pitched you stuff
you didn't get anything out of it and
and I said he said why'd you do that and
I said because making money isn't the
only thing that interests me I love the
process more than the riches and the
fames when people ask me when you gonna
buy the Jets and I always say 25 years
from now they're disappointed I'm pumped
I've always found that that it's amazing
to me like like they're like literally
discipline like I'm like it's three
billion dollars I have work to do I'm
not crippled by the current political
correctness of parenting you're looking
at a kid who didn't see his dad until
he's 14 years old and we have the
greatest
of all time and I love them and he slept
home every single night but I never saw
him once that doesn't mean my workaholic
nature will work for me my kids I don't
think that for granted
I I think that you need to know how to
breathe I know what makes me breathe my
family makes me breathe but I got to do
what I want to do like I have to I'll
just break everybody in here has
different work/life balance you also
have different work-life balance at
different times in your life I don't
think you find balance in any way other
than your own balance and I think that
over communication with your partner and
the variables in that relationship or
the key I'm working harder right this
second than I ever have in my entire
life so I started a levy just wanted to
put all of you on notice like you're not
working as hard as I am and I wanted to
do that because people think they're
putting in enough work they're just not
everybody's talking [ __ ] everybody loves
to hit me up Gary be hustling I look at
their account and they're like playing
ping pong at 4:30 like people don't
understand what hustle is I took one
vacation in my 20s but I have crazy
aspiration you should take 11 but don't
come telling me you're gonna buy the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers so people get my
message confused they're like you're
always talking about hustle where's life
like no no no no no no no if you're a
hundred percent happy like I am then I
got no advice for you you figured it out
so if you know when my rich friends
complain to me about not spending enough
time with their family they're really
easy to give the place to to spend more
time with your family this [ __ ] is
binary stuff is so basic we complicate
it and I'm happy when people have
ambitions that allow them to work 40
hours a week and they're thrilled I have
to move fast like everybody tells me
like Boehner was not gonna be successful
if I move too fast they were wrong cuz
I'm fast let's play out the scenario I
grew too fast I couldn't afford my staff
I had a cup people then people got
scared that we weren't stable they quit
and my [ __ ] got bucked up that's scary
of going to test let me tell you what
happens way more often 90% of this room
is going to slow and has left tons of
money on the table but they don't know
it because it's hidden
it's not obvious to anybody if you're
doing a million but you should be doing
three million but you're going to slow I
mean I love when everybody's like well
it's easy for you it wasn't always like
you weren't with me when I was in my
house printing on that slow ass computer
you know 20% off the case of wine and
then I grabbed the whole thing and then
I [ __ ] woke up at 6:00 a.m. and went
to the Short Hills Mall and just went
and put that on the flyer you weren't
with me people think things are below
them I still don't think things are
below me like nothing is below me I'll
do anything and so like the first thing
is figure out who you are and what you
want and then deploy real self awareness
but I'm telling you the thing that I'm
fearful of and the reason I didn't step
up stage yet is it's been so good for
almost a decade this has been easy
there's so much money out there
everybody's getting money for their dumb
ideas that make no money like people
getting funded for everything so if you
haven't been able to figure out how to
get money you're a triple loser so the
way to answer that and punch me in the
face and tell me that you're not just go
make money instead of dwelling why you
haven't raised it I promise you
something about money money is real
funny
real funny money doesn't care what you
look like
here's most people's strategies in life
[Music]
if you are not capable in 2017 to Google
[ __ ] and figure out what's going on in
the world [ __ ] you we have to start
getting into meritocracy like somebody
should leave if they're not seeing where
the puck is going if you're driving a
truck today you know it's coming
you've heard it somebody told you so
either you take it seriously and you
start educating yourself or you don't
like that's the game that's life and
that's the historic nature of human
beings forever
so just cuz we're now living and it's
our turn to go through something this is
always happened I don't see truck driver
Johnny feeling bad for Rick the
bookstore owner cuz Amazon came along
you're not the first time the innovation
[ __ ] [ __ ] up nobody's crying for the
farmers in Middle America nobody's
crying for the people on Cleveland who
own the docks and so what fifty
five-year-old
oles has to do when he'll is out of a
job is get another job
whatever that job is so Charles is smart
and has skills he's teaching himself
something now to be ready for three
years from now but Charles wants to
watch football here's the punchline the
market is the market what is the 54 year
old gonna do adjust or loose